[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
établir une paix durable entre l'Arménie
et l'Azerbaïdjan
alors que la tension internationale est
focalisée sur la guerre en Ukraine
l'Azerbaïdjan a rompu le cesser le feu
conclu le 9 novembre 2020 avec l'Arménie
à deux reprises depuis le mois d'août
dans la nuit du 12 au 13 septembre 2022
les forces azerbaïques janaises ont
attaquées à l'artillerie lourde avec des
armes de gros calibre ainsi que des
drones diverses positions dans le sud et
le sud-est de l'Arménie face à l'urgence
le Sénat a adopté à une très large
majorité le 15 novembre 2022 une
résolution sur le conflit introduite à
l'initiative de Bruno retaillod la
résolution sénatoriale exige tout
d'abord le retrait des forces azéries et
de leurs alliés du territoire souverain
de l'Arménie et du couloir de la Chine
dans le respect de l'accord de
cessez-le-feu du 9 novembre 2020
surtout le Sénat appelle explicitement
le gouvernement français a sanctionné
avec ses partenaires européens
l'agression militaire
parmi les pistes envisagées figurent
notamment la saisie des avoirs des
dirigeants et un embargo sur les
importations de gaz et de pétrole en
parallèle la résolution invite le
gouvernement à prendre toute initiative
permettant de garantir la sécurité des
populations arméniennes à cette fin elle
demande le déploiement d'une force
d'interposition placée sous l'égide de
la communauté internationale
elle invite également le gouvernement
envisager un soutien de la France à
l'Arménie en matière de capacité de
défense et à mettre en place un bureau
humanitaire ou au Karaba
enfin le Sénat réaffirme la nécessité de
reconnaître la République du au Karaba
et à faire de cette reconnaissance un
instrument de négociation en vue de
l'établissement d'une paix durable tout
doit désormais être mis en oeuvre pour
que l'Azerbaïdjan s'engage dans un
processus de négociation par la voie
diplomatique afin d'aboutir à
l'établissement d'une paix durable dans
le Caucase Sud pour en savoir plus
consultez le site Internet du Sénat
[Musique]